à chaque seconde qui passe il y à
quelque part dans le monde un avion qui
décolle et ailleurs un autre qui
atterrit et quelle que soit l'heure à
laquelle vous ne regardiez il y en a
probablement pas loin de 15 milles
qu'ils sont en train de voler dans les
airs et pourtant à en croire certains on
n'aurait pas encore réellement compris
comment les avions volent plan vraiment
c'est pas très rassurant non il faut
dire que si on essaye de se renseigner
sur le sujet il semblerait qu'il y ait
plusieurs théories concurrentes pour
être clic et le vol des avions et il ya
même des débats assez violents entre les
défenseurs de l'une ou de l'autre qui se
prennent le bec sur des forums d'initié
alors aujourd'hui on va regarder
ensemble cette question et je vous
rassure tout de suite on comprend très
bien comment les événements vol pour
commencer expliquant en quoi le fait
qu'un avion vol est a priori plutôt
étonnant et pour ça on peut faire la
comparaison avec une fusée quand une
fusée décolle elle est soumise à son
poids du fait de la gravité et d'un
autre côté ces moteurs lui fournisse une
force qu'on appelle la poussée qui vient
s'opposer à ce poids ce qui me permet de
s'élever et si on veut être complet on
peut rajouter que dans l'atmosphère on a
aussi des frottement de l'air qui
s'opposent au mouvement et forment ce
qu'on appelle la traînée maintenant un
avion c'est assez différent il est aussi
soumis à son toit qui évidemment
verticale
mais cette fois les moteurs fournissent
une poussée horizontale alors ça permet
à l'avion d'avancé 1 c'est très bien il
suffit d'ailleurs lui aussi entraîné
mais vous voyez que ça ne vient pas
compenser le poids
alors comment l'avion fait-il pour tenir
en l'air eh bien il subit en fait une
force supplémentaire qu'on appelle la
portance qui est dirigée verticalement
vers le haut et permettent de compenser
le poids de sorte qu en régime de
croisière l'avion reste à une altitude
constante et la question c'est donc d'où
vient cette force de portance et bien
pour comprendre son origine il va
falloir s'intéresser à l'air dans lequel
baignent l'avion et qui va jouer un rôle
essentiel c'est la différence majeure
avec une fusée 1 sur un astre sans
atmosphère on peut très bien faire
décoller une fusée
ce qui est quand même pratique pour
revenir de la lune par exemple par
contre un avion ça ne marcherait pas un
avion a besoin de l'air pour voler une
manière de poser le problème c'est
d'imaginer l'air immobile et l'avion qui
se déplace le dans horizontalement une
certaine vite
grâce à la poussée de ses moteurs mais
une autre façon équivalente de le voir
c'est de se placer du point de vue de
l'avion dans son référentiel et cette
fois c'est plutôt l'avion qui est
immobile et l'eire qui lui arrive dessus
comme du vent si vous voulez hein
on parle parfois de vent relatif et
d'ailleurs cette image du vent arrivant
sur l'avion me permets de souligner que
tout ce qu on va discuter aujourd'hui
s'applique de façon analogue au voilier
une voile et une aile d'avion c'est
essentiellement la même chose et pour
les deux la question est la même comment
le vent relatif peut créer une force et
dans le cas de l'avion la portance qui
le maintient en l'air et bien essayons
d'y répondre
une première hypothèse très simple ce
serait d'imaginer que l'avion se
maintient grâce à l'impact de ce vent
qui vient frapper la face inférieure des
ailes comme les ailes ont toujours une
petite inclinaison à qu'on appelle
l'angle d'attaqué
c'est assez logique d'imaginer que
l'avion en quelque sorte prend appui sur
l'air pour se maintenir comme avec un
ricochet cette hypothèse al'avantage
d'être simple et on peut facilement
calculer la portance qu'on obtient en
fonction de la vitesse de la densité de
l'air et de l'angle d'attaqué mais
malheureusement si on fait ce calcul on
trouve des valeurs de portance bien trop
faible pour expliquer pourquoi les
avions volent et en plus il ya certaines
situations pour lesquelles cette
explication ne fonctionne manifestement
pas notamment par exemple pour des
voiliers qui remonte au vent c'est à
dire se déplacent entre 45 et 90 degrés
face au vent est bien avec cette simple
théorie de l'impact de l'air ça ne
devrait pas être possible
les voiliers devraient même reculer et
pourtant ils avancent malgré tout l'idée
à un fond de vérité
on sait que l'air est un gaz composé de
molécules et donc oui ces molécules
entre en collision avec les ailes des
avions mais pas de cette façon là le
point important c'est que dans un gaz
les molécules sont en permanence en
déplacement très rapide à température
ambiante les molécules qui composent
l'air ont une vitesse d'environ 350
mètres par seconde 1 plus de mille
kilomètres heure et elles entrent en
collision les unes avec les autres à un
rythme effréné
chaque molécule subi plusieurs milliards
de collisions par seconde et donc même
en l'absence complète devant les
molécules de l'air autour de nous sont
extrêmement agitée mais l'eire n'a pas
de mouvement global car toutes les
vitesses se compensent maintenant si
vous avez du vent à disons 50 km heure
eh bien ça ne fait que rajouter un léger
mouvement
global uniforme à ce chaos de molécules
qui s'entrechoquent en permanence alors
pourquoi c'est important de parler de
cette agitation microscopique des
molécules bien parce qu'évidemment elle
vienne à tout moment frapper tous les
objets vous y compris un et bien entendu
les ailes des avions
quand un avion est au sol 1 à l'arrêt
sur la piste il subit une quantité
astronomique de collisions la part des
molécules de l'air notamment sur ses
ailes mais tout ce qu'on pense les chocs
sur la face inférieure sont équilibrés
par ceux de la face supérieure
en revanche quand il est en mouvement à
une certaine vitesse ces collisions
existe toujours des deux côtés un mais
il va y avoir légèrement plus de
collisions sur la face inférieure des
ailes est légèrement moins sur la face
supérieure et c'est cette différence qui
va créer la portance qui permet aux
avions de se maintenir dans les airs
alors évidemment il nous reste à
comprendre pourquoi il y aurait plus de
collisions d'un côté que de l'autre
mais d'un point de vue fondamental au
niveau microscopique
il n'y a aucun mystère dans la portance
c'est une affaire de différentiel de
collisions des molécules de l'air sur la
surface des ailes alors creusant un peu
pour comprendre ce qui se passe on peut
prendre le profil d'une aile c'est à
dire une vue en deux dimensions en coupe
ça ressemble souvent à ça et essayer de
visualiser la manière dont l'air
s'écoule au tour quand l'avion avance
je rappelle qu'on se mette du point de
vue de l'avion 1 donc on imagine l'ale
immobile et l'eire qui lui arrive dessus
à une certaine vitesse pour visualiser
l'écoulement de l'air on a deux
solutions
d'un côté on peut faire des expériences
en soufflerie on place les ailes dans un
tunnel avec un flux d'air et en
injectant de la fumée à certains
endroits dans le flux en amont de l on
peut visualiser sa trajectoire
vous voyez sur cette vidéo les lignes
formé par la fumée évidemment entre ces
lignes il ya aussi un écoulement assez
juste qu'on ne voit pas parce qu'on n'a
pas injecté de la fumée partout
l'autre solution pour visualiser ces
flux c'est de faire une simulation avec
un ordinateur
il se trouve que les équations qui
régissent la mécanique d'un fluide comme
l'air sont bien connus on les appelle
les équations de navier stokes et elles
nous permettent de simuler un écoulement
autour d'une aile de forme de données
c'est ce que j'ai fait par exemple ici
vous voyez le profil de l'est là un
certain angle d'attaqué et les lignes
qui sont crasse et représentent les flux
d'air et montre la façon qu'ils vont
contourner l on retrouve évidemment le
même type de motif qu en soufflerie
il faut donc imaginer que si on lâchait
petit objet léger dans l'écoulement
disons une poussière et bien il suivrait
la trajectoire de la ligne de flux sur
laquelle il se trouve
cette représentation nous permet de voir
comment les flux d'air se déplace et en
fait il n'ya pas que ça vous savez
peut-être que l'air à une certaine masse
volumique une densité on ne réalise pas
au quotidien mais un mètre cube d'air
pèse un peu plus d'un kilogramme sauf
que cette densité peut varier
elle dépend de la quantité de molécules
présentes à un endroit donné qu' elle
même dépend des flux d'air est justement
les équations qu'on utilise pour la
simulation nous donne aussi la densité
de l'air qui s'écoule et la voici
représenté ici autour de notre aile en
blanc ce sont les zones où la densité
est normal en rouge les zones où l'air
est plus compris mais la densité est
plus élevé et en bleu celle inverse la
densité est plus faible et ses
variations de densité sont importantes
parce qu'elle influence directement la
quantité de choc que les molécules de
l'air font subir à la surface de l aile
dans cette configuration à cause des
variations de densité c'est à dire de la
quantité de molécules présentent la face
supérieure de l'ale va subir moins de
chocs de la part de ces molécules et la
face inférieure on subira plus et c'est
cette différence qui crée la portance
cette variation de la densité de l'air
autour d elle et donc de la quantité de
choc moléculaire on peut l'exprimer
comme une variation de pression l'air
soul elle est en légère surpression et
l'air au dessus en légère dépression et
c'est ce différentiel de pression qui
permet de calculer l'importance une
illustration frappante de ces phénomènes
c'est qu'on voit parfois des sortes de
nuages se former au dessus des ailes des
avions et il s'agit en fait de
condensation de gouttelettes d'eau
provoquée par la chute de pression sur
la face supérieure pour essayer de
comprendre un peu plus d'où viennent ces
différences de pression qui crée la
portance on peut retourner notre
simulation des flux d'air une chose que
je n'ai pas encore montré sur le
graphique des lignes de flux c'est que
la vitesse de l'air varie aux différents
endroits
regardez si je lâche une poussière ici
elle avance à une certaine vitesse et
puis elle subit une accélération se
déplace plus vite avant de ralentir à
nouveau sur le schéma on peut s'amuser a
indiqué avec un code couleur la vitesse
sur les lignes de flux rouge correspond
aux vitesses les plus élevées et bleu
aux vitesses les plus faibles et vous
voyez qu au voisinage de l on a des
sacrées différences vous remarqué
d'ailleurs peut-être quelque chose
les zones de vitesse élevée
correspondent
exactement aux zones de faibles
pressions qu'on a vu tout à l'heure et
les zones de vitesse plus faibles aux
zones de haute pression regardez je vous
mets la comparaison ce lien qu'on
observe entre vitesse de l'est
répression il n'est pas dû au hasard
c'est ce qu'on appelle parfois le
principe de bernoulli le long d'une
ligne de flux d'air il y a une relation
qu'on peut démontrer et qui lie
nécessairement la pression et la vitesse
de sorte que quand la vitesse augmente
la pression diminue et inversement
on peut donc dire que d'une certaine
façon c'est grâce au principe de
bernoulli que la portance existe et que
les avions peuvent voler alors il faut
l'avouer ce principe de bernoulli n'est
pas hyper simple à appréhender
associer une augmentation de la vitesse
à une baisse de pression peut paraître
un peu contre intuitif et en plus ce
principe il faut faire un peu attention
à comment on applique on a envie de
penser que de façon générale vitesse
égale dépression mais c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça parce que ça s'applique
le long d'une ligne de flux petite
parenthèse d'ailleurs une conséquence de
ça c'est qu'on illustre parfois le
principe de bernoulli de cette façon en
soufflant sur le dessus d'une feuille et
en montrant qu'elle se redresse mais ça
n'est pas exactement une bonne
application du principe de bernoulli et
c'est pas ce qui se passe avec un avion
1 où l'air se déplacent des deux côtés
et c'est important pour avoir le droit
de comparer les pressions bref donc
c'est bernoulli qui fait voler des
avions très bien sauf que pour une
raison qu'on verra tout à l'heure
certaines personnes ne sont pas d'accord
avec cette explication et une autre
théorie supposément plus correct a été
proposé
basée sur les principes énoncés par
newton alors voyons donc cet autre
explication du vol des avions qui n'est
pas dû à newton lui-même mais qui est
une conséquence de ces principes
quand on observe les flux d'air autour
d'une aile vu d'assez loin on peut noter
une chose l'air arrive
initialement avec une vitesse parallèle
au sol mais après avoir passé l
il ressort avec une vitesse légèrement
diriger vers le bas à la fois du fait
que par en dessous il doit contourner l'
aile et part au dessus il est dévié en
épousant le profil de l'aide pour
provoquer ce changement de vitesse la
deuxième loi de newton nous dit que
l'air a nécessairement subi une force
force qui a été exercée sur lui parle
elle un but qui car bien d'autres oui
sauf que newton nous a aussi légué un
autre principe celui de l'action
réaction qu'on appelle parfois la
troisième loi de newton ce principe do
dit
s'il elle exerce une force sur l'air et
bien l'air exercera une force opposée
sur l'ale force dirigée vers le haut
donc et cette force
et bien c'est l'importance qu'on cherche
et finalement ce serait donc newton
plutôt que bernoulli qui ferait voler
les avions
cette explication à la new town elle est
absolument incontestable c'est la
physique de base
pas besoin de parler de pression comme
avec bernoulli et donc certains la
considèrent comme meilleur un plus
correct que celles basées sur le
principe de bernoulli et c'est assez
amusant de voir des gens débattre pour
défendre de l'une ou l'autre de façon
parfois assez véhémente voire violente
bah oui on est sur internet
mais ce qui est drôle c'est que ces deux
explications sont en fait rigoureusement
les mêmes en utilisant les équations de
la mécanique des fluides de navier
stokes
on peut montrer mathématiquement que la
force de portance calculé par le
principe de bernoulli est exactement
égale à celle de la troisième loi de
newton et quelque part d'un point de vue
physique c'est pas du tout surprenant 1
mais bon visiblement beaucoup ne l'ont
pas vu et continue de défendre avec
ferveur l'une plutôt que l'autre a pour
ma part son plan pédagogique je trouve
quand même l'explication à la newton pas
très éclairante
oui du fait de l'action réaction l'air
est forcément dévié vers le bas mais
contrairement au principe de bernoulli
ça nous dit absolument rien de la nature
des forces qui explique l'importance
juste qu'il y en a forcément une mais
bon retenez que ce débat newton versus
bernoulli est un faux débat les deux
explications sont parfaitement correcte
et quantitativement complètement
équivalente bien alors faisons un petit
bilan de ce que nous avons appris au
niveau fondamental
on comprend très bien d'où vient la
portance on a des phénomènes de
surpression dépression qui sont reliés à
la vitesse de l'écoulement d'air autour
de l'elsasser bernoulli et qui se
traduisent au niveau microscopique par
un différentiel de choc des molécules de
l'air sur les phases d elle et qu'on
voit de plus loin par le fait que
l'écoulement d'air est globalement dévié
vers le bas ça c'est newton
cette théorie elle explique vraiment le
phénomène de portance mais pour calculer
cette importance elles partent du
principe qu'on connaît la manière exacte
dont l'air c'est cool autour de l'ale sa
vitesse en tout point ce qu'on appelle
le champ des vitesses une question qu'on
peut se poser maintenant c'est qu'est ce
qui détermine ce champ des vitesses
comme je voulais dit la manière dont un
fluide que
l'air c'est cool est réglée par des
équations qui sont connus les équations
de navier stokes et qui permettent en
principe de calcul et le chant des
vitesses quand on connaît la forme et la
taille de l'ale l'angle d'attaqué et la
vitesse de déplacement en pratique ce
qu'on aimerait savoir c'est comment
avoir une bonne portance aussi élevé que
possible
il ya par exemple une chose qui ne se
calcule pas très bien avec les équations
mais qui est bien connue d'expérience
c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire n'importe
quoi avec l'angle d'attaqué au delà d'un
certain angle en général autour de 15
degrés
l'air se met à tourbillonner au dessus
de la face supérieure et cela perturbe
complètement les flux et provoque une
perte importante de portance c'est ce
qu'on appelle le décrochage qui est bien
connu des pilotes d'avion au delà de ce
phénomène quand des ingénieurs
conçoivent des ailes pour un avion ou un
planeur ce qu'il cherche à faire c'est
trouver une forme qui va permettre
d'avoir le plus de portance possible et
le moins de traînée également la
difficulté c'est que en pratique
résoudre les équations de navier stokes
et trouver la forme exacte de
l'écoulement d'air même avec un gros
ordinateur c'est presque impossible car
les calculs sont très très lourd
et de fait on peut se demander s'il
existe des principes qui permettent de
comprendre l'impact des différentes
formes modèle sans avoir à faire tout ça
et bien il y en a un qui semble
séduisant et qui est fréquemment
mentionnés c'est celui dit du temps de
transit égal ce principe nous dit que si
l'air va plus vite sur le dessus d'une
aile que sur le dessous et bien c'est
tout simplement parce que du fait de la
forme de l'ale la trajectoire à
parcourir est plus grande au dessus qu
en dessous et donc l'air doit aller plus
vite au dessus pour compenser un pour
que les deux flux d'air se rejoignant
sorties ont dit que leur temps
transitera égal le problème de cette
explication c'est qu'elle est
complètement fausse
d'une part on arrive très bien à faire
voler des avions avec des ailes profil
symétrique où la distance à parcourir
est la même sur les deux faces un cas
extrême d'ailleurs étant l' avion en
papier qui a des ailes plate et en plus
quand on compare les temps de parcours
de l'air qui passe au dessus et en
dessous soit par une simulation soit par
une expérience eh bien ça n'est pas vrai
que les flux se rejoignent en fait le
flux d'air supérieure est de toute façon
beaucoup plus rapide que ça on le voit
en soufflerie si on lâche de la fumée
par courtes impulsions comme sur cette
vidéo
ça permet de suivre les paquets de fumée
et de voir que
qui passe au dessus arrivant sortie bien
en avance par rapport à ceux qui passent
en dessous et paris sur la simulation si
on lâche plein de poussière
simultanément en amont dans le flux est
bien les poussières qui passe par le
dessus atteignent l'arrière de l'ale
bien plus rapidement que les autres donc
ce principe du temps de transit égales
entre les deux phases de l efo est en
fait de façon assez étonnante
c'est à cause de ça que certaines
personnes mal informées en sont venus à
rejeter aussi le principe de bernoulli
il faut dire que les deux explications
ont été souvent présentés ensemble on
lit parfois l'air doit aller plus vite
au dessus à cause du chemin plus long et
bernoulli fait que cette vitesse plus
élevée engendre une dépression et donc
de l'importance mais il faut bien voir
que ce sont deux choses différentes 1
bernoulli nous explique l'origine de la
portance quand on a un certain
écoulement d'air la théorie du temps de
transit égal elle prétend expliquer les
caractéristiques de l'écoulement à
partir de celle de l'ale et cette partie
est fausse mais ça ne remet pas du tout
en question le principe de bernoulli ok
bon mais si cette approche est fausse
comment on fait pour concevoir
simplement des ailes d'avion qui marche
bien et bien au tout début du 20e siècle
une très jolie solution a été proposée
par deux chercheurs un allemand martin
coûta et un russe nicolay joukovski
alors comme vous vous en doutez à cette
époque qui avait pas d'ordinateur et
donc résoudre les équations de navier
stokes pour calculer la portance c'était
totalement exclue et du coup ils ont
fait un truc assez remarquable ils ont
simplifié à mort le problème pour ça ils
ont fait un certain nombre d'hypothèses
dont on sait qu'elles sont toutes
fausses 1 dans le cas qui nous préoccupe
mais ils ont obtenu en contrepartie une
forme très simplifiée des équations de
navier stokes qu'ils ont pu résoudre à
la main pour toute une famille de profil
d'aile ça leur a permis de prédire la
forme des écoulements d'air autour de
ses ailes et donc de calculer la
portance avec le principe de bernoulli
évidemment un des points remarquables de
leur approche concernant une hypothèse
en particulier le fait ne supposez que
l'eire n'a pas de viscosité alors d'une
part déjà ses faux seins l'air à une
certaine viscosité mais en plus de ça on
sait que cette viscosité est
indispensable pour expliquer les profils
d'écoulement qu'on observe en gros on
peut démontrer que s'il n'y avait pas de
viscosité on aurait que des écoulements
qui ne craignent ni très
une importance ça s'appelle le paradoxe
de d'alembert
sauf que le truc qui les arrangeaient
c'est que cette viscosité elne agit en
fait de façon significative que vraiment
tout près du profil de l'ale dès qu'on
s'éloigne un peu on peut la négliger est
ce qu'on fait dans la proche du foutage
de cops qui sait qu'on néglige carrément
la viscosité partout mais on la prend en
compte via un critère de sélection des
solutions des équations ce critère
permet de ramener le rôle total de la
viscosité à un seul paramètre qu'on
appelle la circulation et qui est en
gros la quantification du tourbillon qui
se forme autour de l'ale du fait des
variations de vitesse pour visualiser sa
si par exemple je représente les
vitesses de l'air par des petites
flèches et que je me place cette fois
dans le référentiel de l'air 1 où il est
immobile au loin eh bien vous voyez que
l'air soul elle est poussée vers l'avant
et que l'air au dessus de l'oeil est
attiré à l'arrière ce qui crée un
tourbillon global c'est ça qu'on appelle
la circulation dont l'intensité peut
être directement relié à la portance
alors je vous passe les détails
techniques mais ce que je veux que vous
reteniez c'est que coûte à joukovski ça
n'est pas une autre théorie de la
portance qui viendrait concurrencer ou
remplacer ce qu'on a vu avant c'est
plutôt un cadre d'analysé à la main sans
ordinateur pour essayer de prédire la
forme du champ des vitesse de
l'écoulement pour certains types d'elle
et notamment ceux ayant ce qu'on appelle
un bord de fuite tranchant comme ceci
donc dans mon schéma coûte à joukovski
se place ici
ça permet de calculer des écoulements et
ensuite on utilise comme toujours
bernoulli pour calculer la portance ce
qui est intéressant avec cette approche
sait déjà que historiquement elle a été
très féconde pour l'étudier des
écoulements mais en plus
mathématiquement elle est vraiment très
belle si vous aimez les équations
différentielles et l'analyse complexe je
vous conseille d'aller jeter un oeil
évidemment ces travaux là son ancien il
date de 1902 et 1905
c'était exactement l'époque des premier
vol des frères wright et bien sûr les
choses ont pas mal évolué depuis et
notamment maintenant on sait mieux
résoudre les équations de navier stokes
avec des ordinateurs en se passant de
certaines des hypothèses qui avaient été
faites par coûter à joukovski et ça
permet de préciser un certain nombre de
phénomènes nouveaux par exemple quand on
regarde les profils d'elle en 3d et plus
seulement de d on sait que la différence
de pression entre le dessus et le
dessous d'elle elle entraîne un flux
tourbillonnant aux extrémités qu'on
essaye d'ailleurs 2
contrôlé avec l'aide de ses petites
ailettes verticales qu'on retrouve sur
certaines l on est capable aussi
d'étudier un certain nombre de
phénomènes d'instabilité et de trouver
des astuces pour essayer de retarder le
phénomène de décrochage des avions quand
l'angle d'attaqué augmente alors malgré
tout certains d'entre vous ont peut-être
entendu qu'il y a quelques années en
2016 un groupe de physiciens danois a
proposé une soi disant nouvelle théorie
censé mettre au placard tout ce qui
avait été dit avant et nous expliquant
que tout était faux mais que eux avaient
enfin tout compris alors j'étais déjà
méfiants parce qu'ils ont fait un
marketing d'en faire des vidéos sites
web bouquin etc nous expliquant qu'ils
avaient découvert je cite le secret du
vol mais en définitive l'article
scientifique à semble-t-il eu un impact
assez faible il est d'ailleurs peu citée
par les chercheurs du domaine
alors je me suis un peu plongé dedans et
sans être un spécialiste j'ai
l'impression que ce qu'ils racontent est
certainement correct 1 mais ça n'est pas
du tout une nouvelle théorie
en gros ils ont utilisé des grosse
simulation des équations de navier
stokes en 3d un stationnaire tout ça sur
un superordinateur et ils ont mis en
évidence un certain nombre de choses
notamment d instabilité en arrière de
l'ale qui ont un rôle dans les détails
du profil de vitesse alors très bien
mais d'une part ça ne remet absolument
pas en question la portance selon
bernoulli au newtown comme vous voulez
mais contrairement à ce qu'il dit ça ne
montre pas du tout que coûte à joukovski
est faux ou que la circulation n'existe
pas revenons à mon schéma pour bien
comprendre cette approche supposément
nouvelle se place au niveau de la
prédiction du champ des vitesses avec
leur grosse simulation les physiciens
danois mettent en évidence des choses
que par essence 1 on peut pas capturé
avec les calculs de kutahya joukovski
très bien mais de là à appeler ça une
nouvelle théorie à dire que les autres
ont tout faux et que eux ont découvert
le secret du vol
il me semble qu'il ya une grosse
survente des résultats mais bon vous
savez que ça existe aussi chez les
scientifiques
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura donné
une vision un peu plus clair de comment
les avions volent
vous pouvez donc dormir tranquille lors
de votre prochain décollage pour les
plus curieux j'ai écrit un billet de
blog qui complètent cette vidéo qui
donne quelques détails techniques
notamment sur la manière dont j'ai fait
des simulations que je voulais montrer
et je mettrai probablement le code en
partage
un merci particulier aux professeurs
babinski de cambridge qui m'a autorisé à
montrer ses vidéos de visualisation des
flux d'air en soufflerie
comme toujours abonné ou la cloche tout
ça les actus la chaîne c'est facebook et
twitter et on se retrouve bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]